welcome to the opening ceremony of
Superbad rapid and Blitz tournament in
Warsaw second lack of grantchester will
have the opening ceremony starting soon
withdrawing the floats and of course
with speeches and simultaneous
exhibition chest fans are waiting for
Magnus Carlson youngster of Duda so
let's go and see the action
it was great I had a lot of fun seeing
uh Magnus here uh after a very long time
it was definitely exciting for the fans
I think it went very well very grateful
for to Augusta for organizing it
hold on
thank you you and especially to the
chess player and to our listening yes
[Music]
the simul was quite amazing everybody's
excited to play all these gangsters here
in Poland I think everybody is ready for
at the start of the tournament the games
are going to be absolutely fire it was
amazing opening ceremony all just fans
were happy to play in the simultaneous
exhibition and now let's get back to the
games
foreign
[Music]